the Celtics Irving's doctors Irving have
decided here that his season is over
there are hopes of winning a conference
championship feeding Cleveland - they're
obviously dimmed down this franchise is
really built for the next few years of
being at the top tier of teams in the
league and who wouldn't want to be a
part of that love you Kyrie you have to
trade very careful on the emotions and
the confidence of these young guys I'm
excited for the opportunity until we
roles are simply not clearly defined
there are times where I think about
having number 11 in the Raptors
hopefully one day and I mean that's a
dream God will have me back I plan on
resigning here next year
[Applause]
for me is not so much an added pressure
it's adding a great challenge they got
one
the finals without their so for him to
come back it's going to take them some
time to find themselves this is a place
for me
very bright applause I'm excited to be a
part of it
this was naturally going to take time
and this was naturally going to be
Brad's biggest challenge he's looking
forward to getting out there and getting
started
I'm concerned about this basketball team
glad that I finally have a chance to
come back and really feel like a Boston
Celtic it's never gonna be the same so
Kyrie Irving will never ever be the same
you know she's been a long journey from
having those two nerds in these
surgeries and watching the team last
year and finally getting a chance to
lace them up for the Boston Celtics what
his carrier be gonna be like this he's
the one guy other than what they were
meant to him to get his own time I love
in the game of basketball that's where's
always gonna be I don't do this for the
media and there's polite produce for
saying they did because I let again
and I worked extremely hard at my craft
and I want to be one of the greatest
ever so that's what my focus is he has
all the tricks all the handles he can do
whatever he sees shoes boat or whatever
he could do anything
we all have instances where we're
challenged and things don't go our way
they will continue to lose games like
this the team by the Orlando Magic that
they have no business losing to Kyrie is
now sort of become LeBron in this
circumstance
it matters the type of preparation you
have which are going out of trying to
accomplish what's the big picture she
sounds like LeBron when you Braun came
back to Cleveland from my n is it I have
the championship experience you guys
need to understand that I don't think
that some on team as her faced at just
every single day easy great listening
the khari right there who did not just
sound like LeBron field like the student
became the teacher bike I can literally
remember LeBron soon they're giving
those exact same interviews the
answering the questions in the exact
same fashion for my job is to rigidly
submit myself as a leader of the Boston
Celtics and I respect that they allow me
to be the leader of this team and he
thinks of himself in a weird way as the
old head and that's part of what is
wrong with his self-esteem Kyrie Irving
is the closer will guess what he wasn't
there lashing table to jail the brown
and some of that power struggle is still
evident when you watch the boss himself
before season said I'm coming back
that's means you lost first these roles
need to be clearly defined by Brad
Stevenson if you are a leader your
teammates have to allow you to lead let
your leaders lead things happen and you
got to be able to weather the storm and
we just got to take our lesson you can't
let the moment get too big for you
I'll just try to really be aggressive on
the ball and being the right spots
you can't fight for leadership you earn
the respect of your teammates I'm just
appreciative anytime I get to go out and
play anyway he needs to go in there and
start doing role definition every single
day until these guys get first-round
playoff matchup with Indiana this is one
of those games you really look to Kyrie
Irving to take over you understand the
economy has that take over a building
to the next level Boston and Milwaukee a
nothing
they're having a lot of talent and the
team sucks obviously what's going on in
time
a bunch of nonsense lately she's out
outside noise again the my name is going
into it
I think most people picked the boston
circles to win the Eastern Conference
and they've been awful all year you know
he said she said like it's interferences
so I've done now you're gonna be super
fun come in atomic Trans Am they don't
like each other at all when you looked
at the Celtics from start to finish the
chemistry wasn't there this thing was
just screwed up front of beginning this
really showed that a young man trying to
figure out how to be a better leader he
can go anywhere he really wants to he
really does have his pick up the litter
in terms of Brooklyn Los Angeles or New
York